welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Rebels season three our breakdowns
of Ahsoka episode 1 and episode 2 are on
the channel now and we are doing this
four-part Rebels recap series as a
companion series to give you a kind of
cheat sheet of the Easter eggs plot
points and tie into the largest Star
Wars universe and while Rebel season 1
rebel season 2 are interesting and
worthy of watching all of season three
is when we really start cooking with gas
because thrawn is here please support
our network with one of these Ahsoka
inspired fulcrum shirts at nerd
riot.shop and please subscribe to the
break room for our Ahsoka after show
Wikileaks and thanks to Rocket money for
sponsoring today's video more about them
in a minute let's get started episodes
one and two steps into Shadow Parts one
and two it's six months after the season
2 finale and Ezra has a new haircut a
new green lightsaber and some unnatural
abilities unlocked by The Sith holocron
from malachor it continues to speak to
him through the presence that is the
spiritual essence of that Sith who
activated that super weapon on malachor
Ezra shows off that new haircut but also
turns to show a said scar this is his
archetypal unhailable wound from that
dual with a great Inquisitor in season 1
symbolizing the festering dark side
presence in him they rescue Hondo anaka
and Ezra lets his zugnot partner die and
then uses the force to walk an Imperial
Walker off a ledge yikes Sabine
repainted her armor this season so that
honor pauldra now is ahsoka's more eye
bird because as far as they know Ahsoka
is dead but it's this bird this episode
that leads Kanan to bendu Hera has the
new captain badge since she's been
promoted in the Phoenix Squadron Ezra
speaks to the holocron and its red glow
is in his eyes giving us this close-up
matching the close-up of thrawn's red
chiss eyes later this episode Kaiden
confiscates the holocron and gets
summoned out to the adelon winds by
bendu voiced by Tom Baker who's the
fourth doctor in Doctor Who David
Tennant is now voicing huyang in Ahsoka
bendu is a force user who's neither Jedi
nor Sith actually the word bendu comes
from George Lucas's original treatment
for Star Wars when Jedi Knights were
going to be called Jedi bendu bendu
teaches Kanan how to use the force to
see mostly by seeing past his own fear
so that he can walk past these quickness
spiders Kanan leaves the holocron with
bendu grand Admiral thrawn enters the
chat voiced by Lars Mickelson who will
also be playing thrawn in live action he
is the villain of these final two scenes
of rebels and of Ahsoka the fact that he
shows up here in the premiere of Rebel
season 3 is a very very big deal because
this season was 2016-2017 when everyone
was kind of confused what Star Wars
Legends were versus Star Wars Canon and
everyone was really worried when Disney
made that re-categorization because
thrawn is the coolest character from
Star Wars expanded universe fiction from
Timothy zahn's heir to the Empire novels
in 1991 the fact that Dave filoni put
him in Rebels here shows us how
important those stories are to him and
how we can never forget them so thrawn
wisely outsmarts the rebels plot to
steal White Wings I will start my
operations here and pull the rebels
apart piece by piece they'll be the
architects of their own destruction in
this transition we see his red eyes
watching over their every move as he
will throughout this entire season
thrawn ends up being correct Ezra's Dark
Side influence bullishness causes them
to gain only a few y wings at the cost
of their Phantom shuttle R.I.P Phantom 1
on episode 3 The holocrons of feast Maul
captures most of the Rebel crew and
demands from Kanan and Ezra both the
Sith hologram and Jedi hologram Prime
ball recognizes to being as Mandalorian
insists that he once ruled her people
referring to the season 5 Arc and Clone
Wars where Maul took over the death
watch and the darksaber and took
Mandalore bendu tells Caden and Ezra
that if Jedi instant holocrons are
united they would give the wielder too
much Vision something Kanan and Ezra
learned the value of by recovering the
catholicron from a krytnic cave
resisting Their Fear and bendu warns
Juan's secret is known it cannot be
unknown they returned to Maul's asteroid
base which was last seen in the sudden
death mirror comic run after Maul tries
to blow Kanan out of the airlock he does
a forced spacewalk like Leia will do in
The Last Jedi this episode released in
October 2016 while the Last Jedi was
still being shot because Carrie Fisher
was still alive at this point Ezra and
Maul joined the holocrons and for a
moment Maul sees his destination I see
him
twin Sons this will eventually lead Maul
to Tatooine to find
all right episode 4 the Antilles
extraction after losing a bunch of a
Wings the rebels get a transmission from
a new mystery fulcrum agent using Ahsoka
same symbol based on her to create a
head markings to being infiltrates an
imperial Academy to recruit wedge
Antilles voiced by Nathan Cress here in
their simulation the Tie fighters
explode in a way reminiscent to toys
where the wings pop off to simulate
battle damage when Sabine wedge and
others walk out to the ties they use
this catwalk in lower end of the
cockpits and I love love this
distinction that we see throughout Star
Wars you step up in the rebel ships you
lower down into these bat-like Imperial
ties we actually saw this in the eye of
all Donnie episode of Andor as well I
think it looks so cool kallus actually
ends up helping them escape to repay Zeb
for that ice skate moment that they had
um episode 5 Hera's Heroes so we return
to ryloth where Hera's father Cham and
numo right blurbs these are the same
arbola seven mounts that didn't Jaron
rides in the Mandalorian but they're
actually first seen in Ewoks the Battle
of Endor Zeb punches a scout trooper to
steal his helmet a helmet that Ezra will
continue to use and might show up in the
background of sabine's home and Ahsoka
the cindulas have lost their family
calicori it honors all who have come
before each parent adds to the artwork
to include themselves in the Legacy hmm
family history is Living Art ah so an
appreciation of family history through
ART is a key theme from here forward as
thrawn says this episode to defeat an
enemy you must know them not simply that
battle of tactics but the history
philosophy
ah Sabine Wren is an artist and that
will play a big role in Ahsoka also a
kalakori will show up in Lutheran's shop
in Andor and it's just kind of crappy
that he has one all right episode six
the last battle Rex takes him to a
battlefield from the Clone Wars era they
get captured by battle droids still on
the separatist programming led by
General Kalani this episode shows how
for Clone Wars veterans the war didn't
really end with any true resolution as
they were all misled by these false
motives and political games and because
this is the Clone Wars Vibe episode this
episode ends with the Clone Wars
animated series logo and theme over the
credits
all right episode 7 Imperial super
Commandos Sabine Wren tries to lure
Mandalorian Finn Rao and his protectors
to the rebel cause over a game of cubic
Cod this is from the 2007 novel Legacy
of the force sacrifice we see the
Phantom 2 in this episode as a new paint
job thanks Sabine with activity on the
side they get captured by a group of
Imperial mandalorians led by gar Saxon
voiced by Ray Stevenson the late actor
playing balance skull in Ahsoka again we
learned that some mandalorians just
support the Empire and it kind of sucks
Sabine and Finn Escape but Sabine
defeats gar in hand-to-hand combat and
Finn joins the rebels a key partner from
here Forward episode 8 iron Squadron the
specters meet the iron Squadron led by
Commander sato's nephew Mart voiced by
Zachary Gordon it's kind of a parallel
team to the ghost just younger and
Dumber but both teams have crabby
astromechs and love space waffles Gucci
Terrace is named after Rebels retcon
host Andy Gutierrez and the rebels Recon
staff get shouted out through the names
throughout this episode okay episode 9
the wing katsu job Mando onaka is back
wearing a stupid pirate hat with an even
stupider as Morgan hanging out with him
returning from mirror with that stolen
Imperial landing craft they all headed
to the planet winkathu hoping to get
some proton bombs but Imperial DT Sentry
droids attack these are inspired by the
dark Troopers in the dark Forces game
which would also go on to inspire that
these three dark Troopers in the
Mandalorian season 2. just everyone be
careful with these Hondo episodes
because it'll make you really hate that
loading area for Smuggler's run I'm
sorry I'm just not a huge fan of anno
onako he's kind of annoying all
right episode 10 and Inside Man so back
on lothal Ezra and Kanan rejoin writer
Azadi Clancy Brown's escaped prisoner
who knew Ezra's parents when they were
in prison together we saw him in season
two and Azadi serves as the governor of
lothal and Ahsoka family friend sumar
returns from episode 4 of season one but
he dies when thrawn makes him test a
faulty Speeder Bike the workers wear
outfits that kind of look like color
Swap and arcina 5 prisoner outfits from
Andor thrawn does a whole deep dive on
all the imagery and art that he can find
in relation to the ghost crew including
depictions of loath wolves as well as
murals from Mandalore depicted in an
ancient battle with a Jedi we actually
saw these in Clone Wars and this one
with a woman crying is clearly based on
Pablo Picasso's Guernica also thrawn is
a Jedi Temple guard mask on his desk
like the one the grand Inquisitor wore
Alice reveals himself as fulcrum and the
rebels learn of thrawn's plans to build
the new TIE fighter the Thai Defender
which comes with shields a design based
on the 1994 Tie Fighter video game
episode 11 visions and voices this is a
very important episode to watch this was
the mid-season finale the last episode
to come out before Rogue One released in
December 2016. Maul appears to Ezra in
creepy background apparitions just in
these flashes of lightning but there is
no lightning storm going on this is all
just in Ezra's mind he's freaking out so
they go to bendu where they find the
real Maul who takes Ezra to dathomir and
kanan's being followed closely as they
walk into death miramal explains my
family the Knight sisters were killed
Festival witches they were we actually
saw this in Clone Wars a four-part Arc
starting with season four episode 19
episode Massacre the night sisters was a
force-wielding cult including Maul's
mother thousand who used sorcery to
re-grant Maul the ability to walk
General Grievous killed many of them off
but we know of one Survivor Marin in
Jedi Fallen order and now on Ahsoka
thrawn acolyte Morgan elsmith was
revealed to be a night sister so
everything we can find on the night
sisters we need to pay attention to Maul
places his hand on this leg of a statue
and we see the other statues bisected at
the waist the same kind of injury that
Maul suffered from ganobe actually
inside Maul's home in the mandoa
language he wrote kid on Me on the wall
he's got all kinds of interesting odds
and ends some Spears like the one used
by his brother sabajo press and a battle
droid head he also has a painting of
Duchess sateen Crees sister to Boca tan
and Obi-Wan's former lover in Clone Wars
whom Maul executed with the dark saber
we also hear a piano version of satine's
theme as Ezra looks up at it
[Music]
and it kind of looks like Maul has
defaced this portrait just out of hatred
of Kenobi but the most important object
here is the dark saber Maul previously
wielded it in season five of Clone Wars
and here on Rebels it re-enters the Star
Wars timeline yes I talked about the
dark saber a lot and all my breakdowns
of the Mandalorian in the book of Boba
Fett but this is where it re-enters the
chat Maul and Ezra drink a night sister
potion to merge their minds to gain the
knowledge that the other has from their
Sith Jedi holocron crossover moment and
Maul realizes that Kenobi is on Tatooine
but they awaken the spirits of the night
sisters hey yeah
the spirits of the night sisters Sabine
and Kanan get possessed by these Spirits
they're trapped in the temple and Maul
leaves but possesses of being has picked
up the darksaber and to me that is a
critical moment because I believe the
darksaber is cursed it should have
stayed in here Sabine only picked it up
because evil night sister sorcery
compelled her to do so the night sisters
are behind a lot of this stuff Ezra uses
his green lightsaber and the darksaber
to destroy the altar banishing the
knight's sister ghosts but in characters
like Morgan ellsbeth the Knight sister
Legacy lives on episode 11 13 The Ghost
of Geonosis part one and two Rebel
extremists saw Guerrera returns now
voiced by Forest Whitaker who had just
had a big moment at sawgrera in Rogue
one this is the era of saw that we
actually saw in the flashback of Rogue
one when he rescued Jen Ursa when he was
still bald Saul has gone missing on the
planet of Geonosis that you remember
from Attack of the Clones and remember
the geologians have been mostly
eradicated by the Empire to keep secret
the Death Star construction so Saul
interrogates his surviving Geon ocean
named click clack who draws two circles
in the dirt indicating the Death Star
but everyone else is like what's that
Rex explains that saw his sister Stila
Guerrera died from a geonosian-built
gunship and we saw Stila in Clone Wars
and her death would be a rallying Cry
For The hondurodians Click clock's
Hideout also has a queen egg that would
give the genotions a chance to
repopulate he also has a clone trooper
helmet the arm and head of a battle
droid and part of a destroyer droid the
rebels try to retrieve gas canisters to
prove the Empire's war crimes but they
end up losing them in their escape and
Balor Ghana says The Sinner can't really
do anything about it ah poor genosis
right episode 14 Warhead it's a Zeb
episode thrawn unleashes Imperial
infiltrator droids across the Galaxy and
one lands at Chopper base on adelon
cannibalizing other droids to repair
itself and prepare to transmit info back
to the Empire hidden a self-destruct
protocol but they let it transmit and
then delay the explosion for when it
gets back to its spaceship yet thrawn
from this is able to use this to narrow
down his search Episode by episode he's
getting closer and closer to finding out
where the rebels are now the movies we
cover tend to have big budgets which
sounds nice right but if you want a big
budget for your life rocket money can
help with that it makes saving money
easy rocket money is an all-in-one
Finance platform that helps you save
more and spend less one of our favorite
rocket money features is that it helps
you find and cancel all your unwanted
subscriptions I was wasting hundreds of
dollars every month on stuff I didn't
even use and now I can use rocket money
smart savings account to put that money
aside instead I just chose the amount of
money I want to save and how frequently
rocket money automatically deposits my
money into a savings fund that I can
withdraw from any time for the money I'm
spending instead of saving I use the
budgeting tool it monitors my spending
by category sends notifications when
I've exceeded my spending limits and
visualizes my spend to earn ratio by
month quarter or year rocket money can
even negotiate bills from internet
service bills to cable and phone bills I
don't even know those could be
negotiated once you've signed up for
free you can unlock even more features
with premium it's so easy to use that
there's no reason not to take control of
your finances to try rack of money out
now and support our Channel head to
rocketmoney.com new rockstars or click
the link in the video's description all
right episode 15 trials the darksaber
this is an episode I brought up back in
my Mandalorian breakdowns and it's super
important to understand the Mandalorian
themes Ben Rao gives us the history of
the darksaber legend tells that it was
created over a thousand years ago by ta
Vizsla the first Mandalorian ever
inducted into the Jedi Order after his
passing the Jedi kept the saber in their
Temple that was until members of house
Vizsla snuck in and liberated us we get
this ancient history of the mandalorians
and Jedi at war with each other in
sabine's bunk we see a rough draft of
the mural that she'll later paint on the
fall Chopper we find out is uh got the
hots for her
Kanan and Ezra takes the bean out on a
sword dueling session as reverse shows
her ready position which Sabine
demonstrates while fighting shinhati in
Ahsoka episode 1 Kanan shed some light
on sabine's struggles with the force the
force resides in all living things but
you have to be open to it Sabine is
blocked her mind is conflicted yes
huyang and Ahsoka similarly dismisses
sabine's force abilities but during this
training more eye birds still flap down
to watch Finn Rao gives Sabine
Mandalorian vambraces that she will
continue to wear Anna Soka she uses
these to get the upper hand but Kanan
shuts her down for cheating saying the
Jedi won the war with mandalorians and
it wasn't through shortcuts it was
through discipline now while Dave filoni
was crafting the Kane and Jairus
character it was really important to him
to craft him as an incomplete Mentor in
the style of Gandalf in The Lord of the
Rings it is just too far beyond his
ability to communicate his wisdom to the
younger padawans so he's not a perfect
teacher and he often makes mistakes and
learns lessons himself a little too late
So eventually Kanan finally comes around
and just lets Sabine train with the
actual dark saber it's heavier than I
thought energy constantly flows through
the crystal you're not fighting with a
simple blade as much as you are
directing a current of power your
thoughts your actions they become energy
and as Sabine duels that blade gets
lighter and lighter for her a contrast
to din jarin the Mandalorian who always
struggles to lift that dark saber and we
get this amazing emotional moment from
Sabine as she duels Kanan everything I
did was for family for Mandalore I built
weapons terrible what
Mandalore on friends on family I helped
in simple please please please keep all
of this in mind as you watch Sabine in
Ahsoka because this is where she is
coming from In This Moment always just
wrecks me the Empire wanted to destroy
worlds
and they did
they just looked mine
so with Sabine and Ahsoka in the Ahsoka
series it's not a master Apprentice
relationship Sabine just wants a sister
and we see how messed up sabine's family
is in episode 16 Legacy of Mandalore
they head to cronist a Snowy Mountain
setting that I think is the prettiest
location in Star Wars they are attacked
by super Commandos led by sabine's
Brother Tristan they meet her mother
Countess Ursa who also appears in the
final season Clone Wars by the way and
we learned that house wren is loyal to
the Empire with gar Saxon considered the
emperor's hand Ursa gives Saxon the
darksaber and a trade for her daughter
but Saxon doesn't hold up his end of the
bargain we end up in this incredible
duel between Saxon with the darksaber
and Sabine with Ezra's lightsaber
setting up Sabine to later use this
green blade throughout Ahsoka Sabine
disarms Saxon of the dark saber but
Saxon didn't technically win it in
combat so the curse of none of these
mandalorians earning the darksaber lives
on so being for now decides to stay
behind on Cronus alright episode 17
through Imperial eyes which is how this
episode opens Through The Eyes of our
secret fulcrum spy kallus Ezra tries to
get him to defect and thrawn arrives on
his Star Destroyer the Chimera that was
the name of the ship from his original
novels he trains in a sexy sexy vest
against a DT Sentry Droid the shutdown
word is Rook which is the name of a male
nogri warrior who first protected then
assassinated thrawn in those books this
is such a great thrawn episode and I
highly recommend it bronze hallway is
actually filled with Easter eggs we see
the Holy Grail from Indiana Jones the
Last Crusade lucasfilm loves to do this
just see and or it's kind of weird we
see Clone Commander Greece helmet from
Revenge of the Sith this is one of the
guys Yoda beheaded on kashyyk during
Order 66 we see a bust of an Abbott NATO
that's ello asti's species created for
the force awakens film and then a
digital version of Ralph macquarie's
concept art that Rebels used as a
painting of the fall and then on the
back wall is these are the lizard-like
creatures from Timothy zahn's heir to
the Empire novels which were immune to
the force they admitted these anti-force
Bubbles and of course we see that thrawn
kept the calicori that he stole from the
sindula family because for thrawn it is
all about the art wolf you Lauren from
the ISB appears you remember him he was
the white uniformed officer in tarkin's
meeting room on the Death Star in a new
hope we in this episode thrawn knowing
that kallus is a traitor but he lets it
slide for now another important thing
about thrawn our man is patient alright
episode 18 secret cargo secret cargo
revealed to be Cinder man mothma another
figure who returns in Ahsoka during the
New Republic era but this episode is
important for her and or period and here
she speaks out against the emperor for
the Gorman Massacre she's voiced by
Genevieve O'Reilly I named the emperor
himself for ordering the brutal attacks
on the people of Gorman our
self-appointed emperor is little more
than a lying executioner matma is now
out of the Senate on the run and they
have to fight off thrawn's tied
Defenders and archaeon nebula which
reminds me of furiosa losing to Morton
Joe's men during the sandstorm and Fury
Road it looks really cool Mothman
escapes to dantooine where she sends out
a message to inspire the rebel cause for
too long I've watched the heavy hand of
the Empire strangle our liberties
despite Imperial threats despite the
emperor himself
I have no fear as I take new action we
see Baylor Ghana and general Jan dodana
and we also see the lothal bar from
season one's Empire day so paired with
Ezra's big broadcast in season one this
is the next important mass media call to
action for the Rebel Alliance all right
episode 19 double agent Droid it's a
chopper episode Chopper gets hijacked by
an Imperial Legion the controller there
is a fun moment this episode where the
Spy ship control room is inspired by
George Lucas's first feature thx1138 a
movie that gets referenced all the time
but you know what watch it it's
groundbreaking but also not that good
all right
twin Sons definitely one to watch this
episode opens with the twin sons of
Tatooine and Maul returning here after
first scene Kenobi in Phantom Menace
wanders the desert delirious
he's in my mind's eye
Kenobi
and you just gotta see the behind the
scenes footage of saying we're recording
this in the ADR booth in my mind's eye
Kenobi
Ezra and Chopper sneak off to Tatooine
to save Obi-Wan Kenobi but Ezra sees how
Carson Ruffin irritating the sand is it
doesn't really need to be in this
episode he does get saved once by mall
and again by Kenobi and Kenobi tells
Ezra that Obi-Wan Kenobi isn't the
answer to defeating the Sith as far as
he knows this is just a manipulation by
Maul Kenobi at first has no intention of
fighting Maul until Maul forces his hand
you
have a purpose here perhaps you are
protecting something no
no protecting someone
and this leads to one of the shortest
but best duels in all of Star Wars and
it's all in the build up
[Music]
[Applause]
now Sam Wentworth loves to break this
down in interviews but basically Kenobi
starts in the Clone Wars era you and
McGregor posed with the two fingers and
then he realizes no mistakes were made
during that era so then he shifts to the
two-handed Alec Guinness ready position
from A New Hope but then seeing the
confidence in Maul's eyes he decides to
take another breath and he shifts to the
Qui-Gon Jin pose batter up trying to
bait Maul into trying the same move that
he used on Qui-Gon Maul takes his bait
he tries to do the same kind of
flourishing stab but Kenobi is ready for
him and recognizing that he is freed his
old foe from this Vengeance he cradles
him tell me
is it the chosen one he is
he
will avenge us
chills Maul and Obi-Wan are finally
United and their sense of betrayal from
what the emperor did to them and Maul
dies with confidence that there exists
somewhere a child who will restore
balance to the force this episode ends
with Obi-Wan looking out over the large
Homestead as Aunt baru calls now this
would be a few years after Obi Wan
Kenobi's interactions with Owen and brew
and the Obi-Wan Kenobi series on Disney
plus and Luke I think would actually be
around Ezra's age here they actually use
one of Ezra's character models for the
animation of Luke running okay on to the
two-part finale episodes 21 and 22 Zero
Hour Parts one and two the rebels plan
their attack on the Imperial Factory on
the fall but thrawn catches kallus
giving a Folker message and thrawn
triangulates the vectors of this message
to find the planet such as a system
which does not appear on Imperial jobs
but is represented in the art of the
ancient people of this sector I believe
they called this
the ancient people of this sector this
could connect with the ancient star map
that Morgan lsmith is using on Soca to
find her way to thrawn which I have
theorized could be based on the ancient
rakatan empire seen in the Knights of
the Old Republic games this could
explain why the home of bendu is a place
older than what is known to the Jedi or
the Sith and I just love that all season
long we have had this Arc for thrawn to
study each puzzle piece of art and
history and finally by patiently
allowing gallus to do his thing he got
the answer he needed this is the clever
villainy Star Wars needs more of it's a
reason we're so excited to see thrawn in
live action please don't mess this up
Ahsoka in this episode there is an
incredible space battle the Imperial
interdictor comes back pulling out any
escaping ships back out of hyperspace
but Commander Sato sacrifices himself
thrawn only loses his positions episode
because Constantine defies his order so
that he can get Glory really thrawn
doesn't make any mistakes this episode
that's what makes him so scary Kanan
rallies bendu to join the fight calling
him a coward Perhaps it is the Willing
of the force but the Jedi and all your
kind
I serve the will of the force you know
what we ain't wrong thrawn bombards the
chopper base protected by Rex and zeb's
shield at first but thrawn ceases fire
meanwhile Hera calls Kanan now please
come home love yeah as the series goes
on we do start to get more and more
affectionate moments between these two
Ezra heads to Cronus to recruit Sabine
and we see Tristan In This Moment has an
orange barking on his shoulder pauldron
so Sabine has clearly started decorating
her brother's armor she's kind of like
Harold with a purple crayon she's great
so thrawn leads with a ground Invasion
now wearing its goofy Grand Invasion hat
and he lands with some Imperial death
Troopers we actually saw these Troopers
with krennic in Rogue one so thrawn
surrounds them but bendu move bosses in
the sky with a lightning storm and if
you look closely as they all Escape he
takes out some at-at's at ads Walkers
whatever you want to call him but also
takes out some y wings so bendu was not
kidding about not picking aside here and
he really just wants these Warren kids
off his damn lawn Ezra and sabine's
group disables The interdictor and
kallus gets away in an escape pod the
rebels Escape right past Governor price
not a good look for her they all regroup
on Yavin 4. this is the final episode to
take place in the year 2bby meaning with
season four we will be entering the
final year before the battle of the oven
but I will leave you here this perhaps
the most cryptic moment of the season
and a super important moment between
bendu and thrawn
cannot see
but I can
what what do you see I see your defeat
like many arms surrounding you in a cold
Embrace
now we could read this as what happens
in the season 4 finale Ron is caught in
the cold embrace the many arms of the
Pergo zipping off in a hyperspace but
was that truly his defeat because thrawn
is still alive in Ahsoka but it's
important note that bendu does not say
death here he says defeat still bronze
death whenever it comes hopefully
sometime Beyond is so good because I
don't want him to die in the series his
death his inevitable death May Circle
back to this premonition to show thrawn
dine surrounded by some different arms
maybe his acolytes all dogpiling on him
and strangling him thrawn's survival
from the Pergo may give him a false
confidence that he thinks he already
cheated death according to what bendu
predicted making the guy think he's
Immortal you know what Pride goeth
before the fall okay here it is our
Rebel season 3 cheat sheet starting with
our must-watch episodes all of them I
know I know you're not gonna watch all
of them but the premiere in the finale
are fun and important but I would say
really just for the other Star Wars
titles watch episode 11 visions and
voices episode 14 Trials of the
darksaber and episode 17 through
Imperial eyes because it's just a great
thrawn episode and of course episode 20
twin Suns next thrawn is the smartest
villain in the Star Wars lore he's got
appreciation of art history he knows
ancient star maps and he's got patience
that just makes him such a formidable
foe three mandalorians hate each other
and the darksaber has divided them more
than it has United them for night sister
magic is real and it is a different kind
of sorcery than what the Jedi or the
Sith use and it I believe is what cursed
us with the darksaber and finally bendu
is a mysterious Force wielder who also
surpasses the Jedi or the Sith duality
in a world without Jedi or Sith bendu
and night sisters are far more
interesting so please do us a favor and
recommend these Rebels recap videos to
everyone you know who's watching hisoka
and wants to know what happened to
Rebels but just doesn't have the time or
doesn't feel like watching all the
Rebels episodes huge thanks to Noah Chen
and Jordan Morris for their help writing
this breakdown subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
follow me at avos thanks for watching
bye
[Music]